refugees from reality that's the focus
of tonight's
[Music]
angle the scenes out of Israel and Gaza
are heart-wrenching you know whatever
caused the horrific explosion in that
Gaza hospital it's only going to add to
the larger humanitarian crisis that's
already occurring of course Hamas
started this with its Brazen and
barbaric attacks its leaders wanted to
change the dynamic in the Middle East
they didn't care how many children they
had to murder along the way to do that
nor did they care about the devast
station they knew would be triggered in
Gaza with the predictable Israeli
response so Hamas is looking now for a
propaganda Victory from the
international media that will portray
any Israeli countermeasure as
disproportional but as this unfolds what
about our role look Americans are
smartly and overwhelmingly standing with
the people of Israel but we also have to
understand and avoid unintended
consequences and ask now not later what
are the true costs of America's
involvement direct involvement in
another war in the Middle East now
Biden's about to ask Congress for a
supplemental $100 billion Aid package I
just mentioned Senator Rubio for both
Ukraine and Israel they throw in a
little for our border here of course
that's money that we don't have they
shouldn't be tethered together those
requests and it's money that we're going
to have to borrow or print to pay out
but the money for weapons and
humanitarian assistance that's just the
beginning of what the globalist want
American taxpayers to cover here should
Arab countries be taking on The Lion
Share of the burden to absorb what could
be over a million if not more refugees
from Gaza I think there's something to
be said about the Region's Partners
being able to support and step up
Palestinians however that does not
abdicate the United States from our
historic role that we've played in the
world of accepting refugees and allowing
people to restart their lives here
yeah AOC and others including Bush
Republicans have long believed that it
is America's
obligation to take in as many
Palestinian refugees as we can now I
know what you're
saying why should we take them don't we
have our own problems with our own open
border and why wouldn't those
individuals go to countries close to
their native land they're all valid
points but modern day multiculturalism
we have to understand we see it
everywhere we go it's been a colossal
failure in the United States and
probably because somewhere along the
line the Melting Pot gave way to
self-loathing and critical race theory
if we teach our kids that America is a
rotten racist country and if our
President says that our nation is filled
with Maga hatred then why would Muslims
or any new immigrants want to assimilate
here but the truth is the Biden
Administration has greenlighted the
admission of a total of
186,000 refugees from all over the the
world
11,411 in 2019
25465 in 2022 60,000 so far this year
but to that number add almost 90,000
Afghan refugees from that disastrous
Afghan withdrawal the vetting of these
people is non-existent some are sure I'm
sure a wonderful people and some really
helped us and they should be placed on a
priority list for coming into the United
States with proper
vetting but look most Republicans and
Democrats along the way they you know
believe that the American people are
obligated to put the bill for the crisis
caused by their own poor wartime
leadership there's been a bipartisan
obsession with flooding America with
refugees George W bush allowed in a
staggering
381,000 and four years Trump allowed in
118,000 or so Farm more reasonable but
still far too many now some refugees are
true refugees they really need help and
we can make the argument that they
should be here but right now with the
problems the United States is facing we
simply don't have the capacity in our
cities or local budgets to cover what is
an exploding cost of educating feeding
and clothing people and those Gargantua
numbers now this is the breakdown for
this fiscal year alone Syria and
Afghanistan check those numbers out
countries that are hot beds of terrorism
again 10,000 almost 6500 who's doing the
vetting and Progressive C caucus radical
Jamal Bowman says that we need even more
than that he says we should prepare to
welcome refugees from Palestine while
being very careful to vet and not
allowing members of Hamas yeah we trust
that now we have to recognize that we
live in a country where the rich and the
powerful believe that we we owe a moral
obligation to the rest of the world of
course the rich and Powerful they're not
going to pay that obligation they will
not suffer any of the consequences of
the Endless sacrifices that they ask of
the rest of the people to make but
unless we stop them by beating them in
an election election after election
they're going to keep demanding that the
people sacrifice for their mistakes no
matter the cost and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else